[Music]
okay
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 112 q a segment
evening edition
evening erie edition if we're lucky if
we're lucky if we're lucky um
wow uh hi hi hello
um there are great questions this week
and i just got the discord questions uh
because i'm doing it a weird time and
anyway and there's it's a three-way tie
and i we came live and i haven't had a
time to look at them and it looks like
they're all great and so i honestly
because i'm here on screen i'm just
going to read the one that's one line
because i can quickly scan the one-line
one and i know it's i feel this needs a
clarification too yeah sure yes
absolutely as with the video game that
we are not producing we are also not
going to be putting out a three-way tie
because that would be a vulgar tie and
nobody wears ties
anymore anyway
it's a lot of silence
yeah
yeah no i don't i didn't i don't i don't
know what that means
i was trying to figure out if there was
like a 4d chess reference in there
it's a sex thing
what
you could depict three ways on a tie
that would be a three-way tie
it's a sex thing
three ways yes the three if you do them
right
you know i was thinking of having us
have cocktails for the q and a since
it's six o'clock here now
and then uh it didn't happen no no no i
don't suppose we can have our our
bartender children make drinks for us
that's probably not legal no they don't
do that actually no they don't they
could i'm sure they could literally
transport
we're not going to find out no we're not
going to taunt the gods that way
um
god taunters right exactly okay um all
of these questions look awesome i am
actually not really plea i hope we see
others of these in the future man i wore
a shirt with a button that keeps on is
that is that audible that's probably
probably i keep hearing it yeah
um
i guess i'm just going with a simple
question here from discord this week
what principles do you use to clean your
house without exposing yourself to
excessive chemicals
um
that's a pretty easy one yeah
go for it i mean we got two go-to's that
are
useful for a huge range of things so
these are going to be the particulars
the you know the the president you can
you can reverse engineer the
go for it the two
go-to's are
vinegar white vinegar that has been
diluted with water or not or not you
don't need to dilute it yeah it's dilute
as it is yeah
um
and this is three isopropyl alcohol
um and there's really no reason it has
to be isopropyl in fact the principle
that we use isopropyl as a result of
would probably be better met if you used
ethanol the problem is it's hard to get
um
it's hard to get ethanol you know buying
drinking quality ethanol is too
expensive to do
so i think there's three okay there's
vinegar there's um
white vinegar there's isopropyl alcohol
and there's hydrogen peroxide
those are the three those are the three
things that we have in um in spray
bottles throughout the house and we also
have um
some um
gosh what is what is the abrasive uh
bone me yeah right um for for that sort
of thing and
um
and you know actually public goods which
one of our sponsors sells uh sells a
countertop cleaner that seems very
simple and good um but the fact and and
we use that because we have it around
um but really using stuff that um if you
um get it on you or get it in you won't
hurt you in low amounts is um is the
thing that you want and so at one point
actually this wasn't for cleaning
um but early in the pandemic in like
march 2020 when we were when everyone
was sold out of isopropyl right like you
couldn't get isopropyl or hydrogen
peroxide anywhere
um and we went and bought a couple of
handles you went and bought like three
four handles of everclear that's
actually it's not even ever clear it's
um it's like a low grade plane wrap like
ever clear right so it's just like
whatever that is 180 proof or something
and
which we thought we might end up having
to use for cleaning and for you know
just little little spray you know hand
sanitizer bottles
um and frankly it's it's better because
if you end up drinking that you're not
going to die yeah i mean you're not
going to die for a little bit basically
you shouldn't be drinking isopropyl the
basic principle is molecules that your
ancestors dealt with yeah you probably
have a mechanism for dealing with them
um yeah and i buy them in the white
vinegar that i buy um is is stuff that
you could be using
in your cooking you know we i
we try not to buy food products
especially um low ph food products are
going to be sitting in plastic
and so the white vinegar that you know
you know costco brand is in plastic jugs
and so i'd rather i don't tend to pour
that into stuff when i'm cooking i tend
to buy that in the glass jars but it's
the same stuff other than the container
yeah right so you want food grade
cleaning is perfectly good yeah
i would just say you know these things
have different values right vinegar you
can spray on anything including around
food it's obviously vinegar right
it's a decent solvent right it's
possibly decent at killing stuff off but
not great isopropyl it's good on glass
um i would say actually the isopropyl is
better on glass because of the vapor
pressure and so the reason that i
suppose
no i don't i don't think so so my sense
and heather and i may differ over this
is
the high vapor pressure therefore the
rapid evaporation of isopropyl alcohol
makes it very very useful for certain
things if something gets on a rug and
you don't want to be pouring a lot of
water into the rug in case some of the
dyes aren't color fast or something like
that the um the isopropyl you know you
can
get it in and then take it out and take
out whatever it is that you're trying to
solve um
so anyway it's it's very useful stuff
it's a great solvent for all sorts of
things that you know i uh i did a mid
winter
break job on my bike the other day which
is a gross experience especially if you
have rim brakes because the aluminum
dust from the rims coats everything in
this kind of
greasy black
get some dust greasy paste dust yeah
it's really bad stuff
but you know you can saturate everything
with isopropyl alcohol wipe it down and
then the thing dries almost instantly
and it works really really well so
anyway between those three yeah i mean i
have some perhaps i need to be careful
about color fastness because you can end
up bleeding stuff but it's i mean i i
find it enjoyable because it fizzes on
contact with organic stuff and so you
can you can like see
see where things aren't clean
um and also hear it um i also like
bleach for some things although um it's
it's more dangerous like it's more
likely it's a you can't you obviously
can't drink it um and um you'll destroy
your clouds if you get on yourself so um
i i don't know if i should invoke his
name but there's a very good biochemist
at uh evergreen very likable guy a brit
um
who uh
used to wax philosophic about how he
really he liked the smell of bleach
because he worked with some kind of
bad uh organisms and that you knew if
you smelled bleach that that was the
smell of [ __ ] dying
yeah
um so yep yeah yep
um yeah so i don't know that there's um
yeah the yeah the principle is
um
is it a molecule or very closely related
to a molecule that your ancestors would
have had experience with yeah and i
would say actually bleach not so good in
this case um
but those for those those three main
ones um hydrogen peroxide is a common
molecule vinegar common enough and
non-toxic at all um
[Music]
uh i don't want to say that because
presumably there's an ld50 on it
somewhere but probably it's the drowning
level you know
isopropyl i want to put a little
asterisk on and say isopropyl is a
molecule that happens in in the world
but
i would want to get some sense of how
common it is but yeah and i guess um and
then you know this is gonna sound all
you know
hippy dippy but um
like
you know we we keep things pretty clean
but uh we got one closet that smells
like maybe the mice are back
um the mice are not in the closet
they're in the wall behind the closet
which is why we've you know it's like is
it time to tear the drywall out to deal
with the mice so what i did today
instead of tearing the drywall off um
was i
soaked i didn't soak but i put several
drops of tea tree oil on a rag on a very
absorbent rag and put it in the closet
which a makes the musty mousey smell go
away and i think perturbs the mice as
well yeah if you can actually it's
harder to do but it's better if you can
get it on the mice yeah and then
actually they will take it back into the
wall and yeah
i don't know and then all the other is
like what do you smell like man
it's gross
um
okay uh we could we
we could talk all day about that um
we're gonna move on though
regarding masking children it has been
an unfortunate developmental
interference thankfully children are
resilient perhaps they will develop a
keen sense of communication that relies
on sound and presence in lieu of visual
input what are your thoughts on this
the interference of technology is
equally harmful eyes always on the phone
i agree with
with all of that to a point right like
children are incredibly resilient
incredibly flexible um incredibly
anti-fragile
until they're not and there's you know
there's a i don't even know if this is
the phrase the term that's still used in
psychology but it used to be called like
a critical period and it's like a
critical period for
you know language learning for
uh you know for learning of particular
physical like gross motor versus fine
motor skills like there's there's a
particular
optimal moment during development uh
when if you don't get exposed to the
thing um maybe it's gonna be much harder
to learn it and then at some point if
you still haven't been exposed to it
maybe you can't anymore and so i would
say that um we are
definitely you know depending on the
ages of the kids and whether or not you
know what kinds of families they lived
in such that they were ever seeing faces
outside of maybe their parents that
weren't masked
for two years um that's going to be some
potentially very serious disability that
results um with regard to you know high
school age kids like like our kids um it
has a different you know
there's no critical period right there
they're well past that with regard to um
to like language development and such
but in terms of social cues
as all sorts of stuff is coming online
around um relationships
and um
coming to feel like that's your your
security blanket like oh if i don't have
my mask on i'm somehow naked and i don't
really want to be out in the world
without it um that's going to create
admittedly lower level
of
traumas and
frankly disabilities for kids to be
dealing with well i disagree with you
that our kids are done with critical
periods i i remember several periods in
which they were very critical and
anyway you just sort of live through it
right it's a week and it's over um but
the here's the thing really not like
that what they're really not it's not
you know every so often they wake up on
the wrong side of the bed but it's sure
it's not common
uh
the masks and the disruption of the
normalcy of reading
facial stuff is gonna be
a huge
deal yeah right hopefully it results in
some kind of awareness and hopefully we
actually
come to figure out how to test how much
damage was done because one of the
things that will be tempting here is to
bury that information and pretend it
wasn't harmful
uh
one other thing i wanted to say oh yes
there is potentially there are two
possible silver linings here though okay
one
is that
when these kids
realize
how badly they were betrayed with this
mask thing
it's going to give them a
generational problem with authority
which could be very useful at fixing
planet earth so anyway i'm kind of
hoping that
that that happens and the other thing is
i've made
the argument that learning disabilities
aren't a good thing but that what they
do is they open the door to something
once you're disrupted in your normal
acquisition of the usual stuff that
comes in school if school is passing on
bad stuff and you've been disrupted it
can it can free you from it if we write
we write this in the book in the school
chapter i think or maybe it's the
childhood chapter but um
the disruption itself isn't inherently
good but um being outside of the
structures that everyone else is
naturally falling into is a gift yeah
right like an entire generation of
non-normies i could be i could be in to
see in that generation yeah yeah yeah no
no npc generation
yeah there you go no npcs no normies
okay yep
can you speak on the physiological
dangers of wearing a mask for example
when we exhale we do exhale carbon
dioxide but we also exhale broken cell
particles bacteria viral particles and
other waste matter
i haven't seen research on this but i
wonder the same thing i mean i think i
think
your question
reveals what the possibility is and i
don't i don't know well
i'm a little bit dubious about this
because although it's certainly true we
are also so
radically different from even our recent
ancestors in this regard in other words
okay if masks are bad because you're
breathing all sorts of stuff that you
exhaled that would not ordinarily be
captured right then living indoors too
right and true so and living in cities
and living and going to subways and
[Music]
living around cars
right so there's like a thousand things
going on and um it does seem like it
potentially increases the density
um rather a lot i have no idea if the
mask is doing anything then you're going
to be sitting in your own stew
more i have no doubt it has effects but
the question is um as long as we're
noticing weird things that we're doing
to processes that you know
evolved to function under very different
circumstances let's notice that actually
we're doing that
all the time on every front and it's not
good for us and that's what our book is
about yeah and yes this is one that we
might ask that question of but it's
hardly alone yep that's true
in the same way that heart rate
variability is a good measure of health
is authority slash control variability a
good measure of functioning government
how could regulated expression of this
work in government
hmm
um that's that's going to take me a
little thinking i sort of think i know
what this is getting at so there's this
somebody clued me into the fact that a
concept that is necessary already
existed but in some place you wouldn't
know to look for it okay so the concept
is called subsidiarity and it is a
catholic concept and the idea is oh yeah
everything should be regulated at the
lowest effective level
right the last thing you i mean you know
subsidiarity did not happen during the
pandemic we regulated everything at the
top level and it was a [ __ ] so
this this is the antidote to that you
know the history like how does this come
to be a catholic principle um well you
know catholicism is sort of a governance
structure for a population and so i have
a feeling you know the affairs of the
church are really the affairs of the
population and so somehow it applies but
no i don't know enough about catholics i
wish i could ask my dad
yeah he would have something interesting
to say about it but anyway i guess the
point is
the same idea that you should regulate
everything at the lowest effective
scale
um
also implies that the ability you know
you've got light-handed regulation
and you've got heavy-handed regulation
and the point is
you want as light a hand as possible as
well
right which doesn't mean always
light-handed sometimes some things
require a heavy hand but it should be
used sparingly so
a system that demonstrates the ability
to regulate in this way is the same as a
body that you know has a good resting
heart rate but can also really pump
blood when it needs to and i think
that's what the question is getting at
so
you know a system that that's
interesting i sort of i read i read that
i maybe read it a little opposite but
then i'm not sure exactly what heart
rate variability
is referring to then um
i assume it just means the
range over which your
heart rate can can
be
driven
cool let's go on yeah yeah
should we add social selection to the
evolutionary lexicon
that is a form of pure filtration of
traits and behaviors that isn't strictly
due to habitat mating or blood
like natural sexual or cancellation
well
i do have a category that would overlap
that an awful lot which is
perception-mediated selection
but also we should say that social
selection it is
is invoked in the literature yeah and
perception immediate selection i think
is a more is a
is a better category that that
yeah there's like a venn diagram
possible they're not all it's not the
same category but the point is in order
to have a perception you have to have a
critter and so the point is you know
social selection will involve perception
i think if i'm understanding their their
implication here
so it's overlapping but not synonymous
yeah
um
yeah and it kind of gets at i'm gonna
forget and it's not on the bookshelf
that i'm looking at right now the um
it kind of gets at the four
kinds of systems in which selection
happens that are invoked in
in the
book that i like so much that i've
forgotten the name of that we oh you're
talking about
uh selection in four dimensions yeah
selection of four dimensions recommended
further reading here it is um yeah
jablonka and lam 2014 evolution in four
dimensions genetic epigenetic behavioral
and symbolic variation in the history of
life
um and so you know behavioral
that the behavioral layer symbolic
requires the social as well but you know
there's a there's a lot in that
behavioral layer that isn't
you know sexual selection is
again it's not exactly overlapping yeah
yeah it's not it's not
all right
what's the deal with teeth that's not
the whole question what's the deal with
teeth why are so many of us cavity prone
and need of orthodontia why do we seem
to need modern dentistry to keep them
healthy
what did we do before
so first off we could just point to your
conversation with mike mew from gosh the
summer of 2020. right your dark course
well no it's the it's the mid-times it's
post george floyd um
all right
time is out of joint but
um
so they're two things
there are two general principles yeah
but anyway that mike bew is an
orthodontist who understands this who
takes an evolutionary approach and brett
has a conversation with him on air um
definitely go there and you'll and
you'll see a lot of the answers to this
you'll see a lot of the answers to this
and the basic point about
no your genes didn't go bad because that
doesn't make any god damn sense what
happened is we interfered with
development in a novel way and it caused
your face not to be the right shape
which caused your jaws not to have
enough room for all your teeth which
caused them to come in cattywampus which
then created a
uh a
an industry of people who move teeth
around without reshaping your face yes
and anyway no people didn't have this
kind of problem um certainly a hundred
thousand years ago
um
even ten thousand years ago at which
point most of us were farming already um
it was
almost certainly
um sort of it requires
at least decadence
if not and is then accelerated by the
industrial revolution and the kinds of
food processing and availability of of
sugars and quick nutrients that we have
now let's put it to you this way
um the invention of babies
predates the invention of baby food
you might wonder then
what baby food is and whether it was a
good idea to pulverize everything quite
that much but they don't have teeth
right i cannot eat
right however this might be a made-up
category of need and it could be that
there were things that one could feed a
baby um prior to the invention of baby
food
uh and that would have helped them
develop strong jaws bigger faces more uh
more well-formed musculature and by the
way enough room in their jaws for all of
their teeth yep like sucking on sugar
cane it's not anti-sugar right but um
you know you want to give them a watery
slurpee thing
um with
straw so they get they have sucking
reflex long after when they're supposed
to be doing anything like that or do you
want to give them something harden on
yeah it's the latter
um so
there is a
unavoidable outgrowth of us living
longer we don't live longer at a maximum
but we live longer on average and this
is something you also see in things like
elephants in the zoo where they outlive
the evolutionary expected need for teeth
and in the case of elephants
elephants have a system
it's like a conveyor belt where teeth
move from the back of the mouth
forward and the point is there's enough
teeth unlike a shark which produces an
infinite series of teeth you know
there's some very old sharks how do you
pull that off well you have an infinite
capacity to generate new teeth in an
elephant you have a finite number of
teeth and if you live very long as an
elephant because you're in the zoo then
you run out of teeth right so so this
story yep
given
what we have now
heard and learned and seen about for
instance what wisdom teeth
probably are and how like you know they
the teeth are experiencing themselves in
the jaws around the other teeth and kind
of
you know being where they can be and
sometimes there's not room enough
might that conveyor belt in elephant
teeth story simply be a
that sounds like a totally different
system
from what we've got yet and it seems to
me i run this by people okay um the idea
being wisdom teeth are spares and they
can move forward in in the case that
you've lost a tooth like our is what we
have going on really a totally different
system what have we might say elephants
appear to have going on i don't get a
lot of traction on that idea um
i think you have various different kinds
of systems from the shark system to the
elephant system to the us system the
thing about wisdom teeth is that wisdom
teeth well i mean so sharks
sharks is easy because they're homodan
because all of their teeth are the same
type of teeth and so they just have one
sort of conveyor line and um and all but
mammals are i'm not even sure heterodon
there's all these different dental terms
right but like because we have three
distinct types of teeth inside there's
canines and premolars and molars which
are kind of the same ish
um i'm not even
and i don't remember you know all of the
different clades and mammals have
different um dental formulas and you
know like insects or
insect
insects
rodents i have no idea rodents
insects don't have teeth
rodents don't have canines right and um
boy one of the groups has
canines that look like incisors i i
can't remember but i don't know what the
dental formula for elephants is but it's
hard to imagine a mammalian like a
heterodont mouth
like what would if our incisors dropped
off would our canines move for no no and
then our like our molars no and like
imagine in a cat where they've got these
um
oh what are they the the carnassials
with the fused molars those like
mountain range looking teeth
they're not going to move forward in
their mouth that would be ridiculous
so yeah we have the wrong story about
about wisdom teeth the basic story about
wisdom teeth is uh your jaws collapsed
because baby food and
um there would be room for them and they
would be useful
um there might be some truth to the idea
of them being able to move forward to
replace other molars
but
in general that's not that's not
understood to be what's going on on the
other hand there's such confusion around
jaw shape and orthodontia and all that
flows from it anyway check out the mike
mew conversation it really is
mind-blowing that we have
a ongoing catastrophe with respect
to children and orthodontia that we
can't get over because we can't accept
the right story which is this is not a
failure of genes it's a failure of
behavior and development
yeah
um
boy it looks like it's possible that the
um elephants i'm not actually finding
any good images here um
but that they also have a diastema like
a no maybe no canines and just a like
that it's an elongated incisor which is
their tusks
or maybe they've lost the incisors and
and that's the canines um and then
they've got a big gap and then the
molars are all back here
um i believe that's the case but in
which case if so it's just the molars
that are kind of moving forward is the
idea
and you've also seen they're about
smaller right these big this right yeah
yeah
um
from the top yeah that's from the top
you can show that zach or not
um yeah that's that's the top of a
one and that kind of looks like um
carnacio-like uh in terms of it being a
fused number of teeth fused together
yeah
um all right all right
thank you zach
little
move into elephant teeth
the smartphone
the smartphone and social media seem to
be key tools for authoritarian
governments to achieve some of their
goals
could abandoning them be the easiest
form of resistance
um
well i have accidentally abandoned my
phone it was an immediate pain in the
ass
um
yeah i mean
it's two different things right the
phone and the
software are
are different
in both cases they have the potential to
make life easier or more compelling
and abandoning them because
they are used
for ill
may bring about a cost that isn't worth
paying but it's hard to do the analysis
yeah i mean the problem is you don't
realize how dependent you've become and
how dependent everybody else has become
and so the idea of abandoning these
things in order to fix the world isn't
going to happen because it's going to be
such a hard sell for
it feels a little bit like the personnel
personal responsibility vortex yeah
the cost is just astronomical now that
doesn't mean that you couldn't replace
them with something that did the core
functionality and was immune to the
problem but as an individual you can't
do that right right
okay um now with elon on the bandwagon
have you shifted your position on the
population cliff
i know i'm a broken record love you guys
so i'm not sure what elon has said but i
am going to infer or do you know i think
i think i know what the question is
about i think this is a reference elon
said something about we should worry
more about population collapse
than than too many yeah and you know i
i think we need to worry about both
things right if you if you can do the
buckminster fuller thing then we can
have a lot of people and we can live
pretty well right but we're not headed
that way
that's not it's not the
the means that we are uh we are
utilizing to function we are liquidating
the planet and that's bad and that means
that the more of us
that have to be tended to the faster the
liquidation happens the less time we
have for elon to figure out how to get
anybody off this rock so
that said um yeah no i think you're
right i think we have to actually have
to worry about both things yeah because
we do have you know there's there's
serious reduction in reproduction rate
in a lot of countries
um the replacement
we're below replacement rate in many at
least of the weird countries
and um and yet there's already way too
many of us
well
and there's another dimension to this
which is
you're wired for
producing the next generation and being
a temporary
custodian of humanness
right
if you take that element out and you
decide to do something else an
individual can do that but it drives a
civilization crazy
and you know if there's one thing we are
it's crazy and getting crazier is this
because people have decided that
having kids is a lifestyle choice
no but it may be partially because of
that because the point is
you know as they tried to teach many
people in
grade school by having them you know
tend an egg for a week and see if they
could keep it from breaking the point is
having children
if you're wired correctly is a
clarifying experience because
they ain't that easy to raise it's not
that automatic they require a certain
amount of stuff and
it adds meaning to life right
i don't know i i'm not interested really
in facing a society of people
who
become self-obsessed because there isn't
something else that needs their
attention well that's you know
pre-covered that that seemed like one of
the biggest threats right with exactly
this the
the people of sort of primary productive
age of being precisely self-obsessed and
um
and you know frankly
better that than having kids that they
then ignore or abuse of course but um
but
in fact we seem to have both
yes right
i'm worried about college choices and
not being able to prevent my sons from
getting a vaccine that can do more harm
than good any suggestions love your book
it does feel now
this week for the first time like maybe
maybe these things will fall
i don't know and um
if you've held out this long yeah it
would hold out a little longer and you
know i mean
i don't especially i mean
your son's college age
college-age boy should not be getting
the cover vaccines
right
so at some level you're sort of stuck
with your civilization has gone crazy
and is uh
giving poisons to
especially young men yeah for no benefit
to them so at some level that's that's
the demographic for which this this
analysis is most clear yeah but with
regard to risk but really for all
healthy
young people
this this never made any sense and so
the question is
you know
thought experiment
your society starts
stealing from healthy young people in
order to protect the old and infirm
um you have children what do you do
i don't know you resist with everything
you got you
learned a lot
whatever you have to do to prevent that
from happening is probably what you
should do yeah
if it's possible for the virus to jump
between animals and humans then how can
it be claimed that the unvaccinated are
responsible for variants
there's a lot of claims that are
completely implausible on their face and
and deeper down and yet they persist yep
yeah so i mean yeah that's that is one
of the things
um yeah that you state in the question
that reveals that it doesn't make any
sense pandemic of the unvaccinated um
but it's only one there's lots of them
and yet
it persists
okay
um six or seven
idea
the current insanity is because people
are suffering
the unreal
without present shared experiences
reality is schrodinger's cat
do you think isolation is damaging sense
making
yes
yeah 100 and you know it's really
interesting the way you've phrased it
yeah i like it what's going to make it
worse are
real seeming virtual environments
yeah what a great moment to have tried
out the metaverse yeah
really it could hardly be more dangerous
yeah right we were already and we've
been arguing that part of the reason for
the
the woke hemorrhage
was that you had a generation of people
whose online lives was more vibrant than
their physical lives and so it takes on
primacy but the point is actually physic
the physical world has primacy in
reality
and so that error thinking
that your physical life is is a
an annoyance
is already a problem and if you make the
online stuff that much more
vibrant and compelling right and you can
like pretty up your avatar and
you know not worry so much about your
body this is just a disaster yep
totally
aloha
i moved home to wisconsin from hawaii
because of the facts and mandates i'm
applying to the flccc kindly recommend
dr corey to hire kristin
mahalo and march thank you for all you
do all right
how are you doing and coping at this
moment in time any advice on how to
manage constant stress discrimination
being ostracized from society much love
to you both
to some degree i think we spend all of
the first hour and a half or whatever we
spent um revealing how we were coping or
failing to cope um although you know it
it is true also that we
are in a different position for most
people and for better and for worse and
um
you know we take more public [ __ ] for
our positions obviously because we are
public about them and some people
um
may be living in fear of being
discovered of being out of being forced
to reveal that they're not going to no
way know how but until it comes to that
they don't have to
don't have to have it be out and
and
we never even talked about it we just
knew that we were not that was not going
to be the road that we took um and this
is what we're doing and so you know this
this has been um
insane and intense and
demoralizing and all of that
the flip side of that is um
that we are
recognized when we go out even in even
in deep blue portland oregon where we
live and um i mean just today i i was
only out for a fairly brief period of
time and i was approached by two
different people
um
both of whom with very very different
stories um you know one of whom said why
do you live here like what what are you
doing here why do you guys live here
um
and one of the things i said to him and
also the woman who who approached me
shortly thereafter actually as we were
still interacting
um
was well but what you guys can't see
is that while portland and most of the
west coast and mostly east coast and a
lot you know
apparently a lot of canada a lot of
europe all of this australia new zealand
feels insane and monolithic and
homogeneous with regard to the
sheep-like acceptance of what the guy in
the white lab coat says
that we're recognized a fair bit now and
to a person every single time everyone
who approaches us and it happens
multiple times a week
does so with gratitude and appreciation
for what we're doing and so um
presumably it's a tiny percentage of of
people who we see when we're out who
approach us who recognize us and of
course we're not out wandering around
looking to be recognized all that much
and so what that tells me is that
there's actually a lot more people
who are
who are streaming against this craziness
and have been for a while
um than than we all think and so
figuring out ways and we've talked about
this before figuring out ways
um to just sort of drop hints in the
conversations that you have and even if
it's just you know even if it's the
fedex driver or the barista or you know
the person of the dry cleaners whatever
it is
you know the receptionist at your
doctor's office
um
finding connection in these small places
sometimes can become a connection that
becomes is bigger than that and
sometimes it's just
reifying
because sometimes people don't take the
hint and don't pick up on it but so
often they do
right
i was going to say we also have a dog
who's a very good listener
[Music]
suggesting that maybe you're not
a good listener because you just had
that sort of in the buffer ready to go
it wasn't really like that but i mean i
get it i get it
have you
have you changed your position on
vitamin d supplementation compared to
what you wrote about in the book 100
yeah we have and we and we've talked
about this
i could figure out what episode it was
in
at the point that i wrote a very long
vitamin d piece for my sub stack and
then in the wake of that a couple of
extraordinary researchers one of whom is
a
md contacted me one of whose work um
linda binskin that i had um written
about in my piece contacted us we talked
with them and then you did a podcast
with them the vitamin d podcast that
came out just a few weeks ago
um so yeah on um
the the
general idea we persist with like it
would be better to get your your what
you need that you can get from your food
from your food
a vitamin d um is an exception and
it's an exception for a couple of
reasons one of them is that
the vast majority of of humanity's
vitamin d
access is not from food but from sun
and um modernity has made it even a most
many of us live
so far north occasionally so far south
that winters actually render us vitamin
d deficient
unless unless we are supplementing or or
uv lamp supplementing or you know
getting a burst bike traveling to a
sunny tropical climb for a week in the
middle of the time
um or eating a lot of cod liver oil or
something
and
we cover up we're clothed and we're
inside most of the time and so modernity
itself um
quite aside from our diet has made
most of us vitamin d deficient so yeah
we were we were wrong about vitamin d in
the book
yeah i would say i know exactly where my
errors were i assumed that like so many
other things if your diet is high
quality and you can get vitamin d
through diet that we don't have anything
to worry about there's no reason to
supplement and the problem is
actually diet is a poor place to get
vitamin d you can compensate for a
deficiency with it but yeah basically it
is sunlight not all sunlight you know so
it's only during a limited period of
time even during the day
it's so the point is
we're almost all vitamin d deficient and
therefore vitamin d deficiency is
something you do have to worry about
unless you live a very
uh particular life
so anyway yes we we got that wrong i
will say i mean i think i i think
there's two things in the book that um
you know if it gets if there's a second
edition that would change
um i would i would pick
i mean the vitamin d point is true but
not for vitamin d right so i would
change that um and then we also i think
it's in the
it's either in the epilogue or somewhere
in the health and medicine chapter um we
talk about masks and masks and and cover
just very briefly but we're wrong about
that too but i think those are the two
the two errors that i that i know of
that i would change now
from the book
hello good guys from australia could you
comment on the 17 odd thousand deaths in
england that were solely due to covid
i think this is a reference both to what
you were doing
and then but i've also so it doesn't
originally come i actually got an email
from someone
um referring to the foia request and i
think it's this
i think it's i have it on i i just moved
into a spreadsheet so i could see it um
this is 2020 through third quarter of
2021
um the foyer request was
what how many deaths
um
from covid without comorbidities yep
right and um through third quarter 2021
in the uk it was about 17 000 total
um of which a 13 and a half thousand
were over people over 65
years old so we have 37 almost 3 800
deaths in the uk
um up through
third quarter of 2021 um from covid
under 65 no comorbidities which is
more than we would like
but
really a very small number so the uh i'm
a big fan of john campbell um
there's something else in that video
that people so i haven't seen that i
don't know about the video i this is a
this is from the original foia request
so the video is about
that foia request and it does an
analysis and one of the things he says
that is i hope i have it correct but
it's close to right
is that
the period of covid reduced
longevity expectations in
males by
a few seven weeks maybe something like
this yeah and in females it actually
went up slightly
um and the basic point is
there's a lot that you know there's a
lot it's not in the calculation right
yeah we don't know about long-term
consequences of either covet or the
vaccines yeah but
and what that doesn't include is all of
the other deaths that are coming down
the road just putting you know put aside
vaccines but all the other deaths
because of you know
cancer treatment that wasn't done
right and you know people getting more
lethargic and sedentary and fatter and
in every way and you know mental health
problems like all of these things
all-cause mortality is where it's at
yeah um but in any case the point is we
turned the world upside down over a
an effect that when a
sober analysis is done
was relatively small as far as we can
tell so far yeah
and we did an awful lot of harm right we
did
so anyway uh
it's worth looking at that john campbell
video
yeah well um you keep mentioning it it
would be good to be in the show notes
but i don't know about it you're gonna
have to find it yeah you're gonna have
to remember and send it to me and then
i'll put it in the show notes
um subsidiarity
in the navy we call it delegate to the
lowest level of competence
solid principle in my opinion
so
they have a similar
uh in public health they delegate to the
highest level of incompetence i think
it's sort of a yin yang
yeah
this next one i usually don't read out
the usernames but this is from tranquil
tapir
uh what are your thoughts on the
documents released by project veritas
from darpa regarding the origins of
koben might they be legitimate
i think they are legitimate but what
they imply i mean a and not just the
origins of covet right but you know all
the things
right
early treatment um vaccine safety
everything but they're from but they're
not high level it's speculative is the
problem exactly so it's not 100
speculative but it's speculative this
document appears to be a legitimate
document on the other hand i have to say
i have a hard
time believing
that
the
virus that escaped
was actually intended to be a vaccine
for wild bats
yeah i don't i don't think i believe
that yeah yeah um so you and i both
tripped up on that same thing yeah it
doesn't make any sense for various
reasons for one thing if you succeeded
in vaccinating wild bats you would get
very little credit for it in anybody's
eyes and if you screwed up the thing you
might cause a global pandemic and be
blamed for one of the most colossal
errors in the history of humanity that's
not a you know
it's not a a good
argument for for doing it yeah
i we're gonna not get to so many of
these good questions this week for which
i apologize guys
i am romanian i'm not
right oh the questioner i'm romanian
oh yeah i don't actually none of these
things is true about me i'm romanian 27
gay conservative evangelical question
yeah that's not you that's not me
um thoughts on surrogacy in gay couples
um
ethics of it and also what's the purpose
of gay and evolution
you keep on getting asked you keep on
not saying um but let's so
thoughts on surrogacy in in gay couples
um
the my one
my one hesitation has to do with um
with the surrogacy part right the you
know the the renting out of
effectively the renting out of female
bodies
uh for for reproduction that is not um
not their own that you know that is
generally going to be about um needing
needing to rent out their bodies for for
monetary reasons you know it feels
related
to sex work in this way um you know if
it's if it's a friend of the gay couple
i would feel different about it although
i think that it is going to be
challenging
i can't imagine and you know i know
um
i know that people do successfully um
hand over hand over babies um but i i
can't imagine doing it myself um having
been pregnant so um it's it's
it's got challenges as for the you know
the men who are lucky enough to receive
a
a beloved child i imagine they will do
they have the potential to do a
fantastic job parenting
so i will say
so there's we got to separate
there's a lot of things to separate
surrogacy versus the question of
surrogacy for gay couples right exactly
i would say with respect to gay couples
it is probably the case
that
a human being is wired such that having
a
male parent and a female parent
has advantages
that said
what has a bigger effect is parents who
love you versus parents who are
indifferent and so my guess is a gay
couple that's going to go out of its way
far enough to do this job is probably
way you know the kids way better off
than the average kid based on how much
the parents desire them yeah but then
you might just you know as a gay couple
you might want to make a point of having
opposite sex adults around for your kid
at some point at some points in their
life so they you know see honorable
examples of you know the other sex
around yeah um i have some discomfort
around the idea of surrogacy on the
other hand it's hard for me to imagine
that it's anybody's right to tell you
you can't do that yeah right that i
don't quite see and so it's one of these
things where
you know my discomfort around it i know
doesn't rise to a level to counteract my
sense that actually you have a lot of
leeway to do stuff that may not be a
good idea or yeah well i mean i think
you know there's a lot of things in this
category right there's sex work and
there's organ donation and
there there are yeah right
well
i see it as slightly different i agree
it's not wildly different
um but i see it as slightly different
and
i mean the problem of course is you've
got two questions which is should the
behavior be allowed and is the
um is the restriction on the behavior
worse than the problem and then there's
a question about what society it's in
right if you had right
if you had a fantastic society right
yeah one that was just firing on all
cylinders had its ducks in a row with
respect to ethics and the treatment of
people and you know if if you had a
society that was one that i hope we will
ultimately achieve but something we
haven't been near yet
right and somebody says well who are you
to tell me that i can't you know
uh trade sex for money right the answer
is well in that situation maybe on the
other hand
if you say in our society you know uh
selling your body uh for money uh is to
be tolerated then well of course it's
going to result in a whole lot of people
being exploited by industry and you know
unscrupulous people and all of this so
there's a question about how much harm
flows from it which is partially not
that the behavior is allowed but it's
partially
the society in which it's allowed yeah
it's interesting um i i'm thinking i
never we never watched the um
the new
the show handmaid's tale yeah um but i
read it
actually i read it in my uh freshman
year of college when i was still a
literature major um so you know within
a year two three years i don't remember
exactly when it was published but
sometime mid late 80s
um and it's an extraordinary book i mean
margaret atwood is extraordinary and you
know that's an example of surrogacy and
exactly the wrong type of society
obviously the entire society is wrong um
but you know if you want an example of
you know what what springs to some
people's minds when they think of what
could go wrong with surrogacy there you
have it yeah what could go wrong oh we
can yeah there's lots that can go wrong
yeah for sure and i had to give that
little preamble because i you know
i know there's this whole show that has
gotten a lot of
critical acclaim and critical criticism
and i just we've never seen it
um
probably should watch it at some point
but i'm responding only to the book
um
how does my cat get vitamin d and how
much does he need thank you thank
goodness i read the answer to this and
it is jaw dropping it came in over email
actually from from graph right yeah and
i didn't read it yet because i have too
many things in my inbox so tell us the
answer well
how does your cat get vitamin d well he
probably takes it from somebody else
because he's just he's a cat yeah but
he's not he's not but he actually
literally could take it from somebody
else and i will explain to you how but i
need to tell you an even more mice he
eats nope well actually he'll get some
that way but yeah here's the more
interesting fact that i learned earlier
in researching this vitamin d thing okay
which is that vitamin d
can be made as a dietary supplement by
shining uv light on fat so a slab of
meat that has fat you can shine uv light
make vitamin d and then you i have a
vitamin fat part of the fat converts
into vitamin d yeah
and you get the same photosynthesis you
get on your skin okay now here is what i
think i understood from gruff davies yes
which is that vitamin d in furry
countries it's like like a vat of fat
fat fat
um
personally it has to be in some kind of
form
whatever no i don't i think i think it's
like a piece of meat with fat you can
shine uv light on it and enhance its
vitamin d
content wow i know wow okay okay now
there are two parts to
to gruff's answer on the
the uh furry critter thing yeah and i
can't remember the second one so the
question that he was answering was what
about you know
creatures
[Music]
great question right
um so the part about the furry critters
apparently the vitamin d is made on the
fur and then ingested no
what
well on the fur well and then ingest it
well okay for a cat would ingest it but
how would other animal not all animals
lick themselves how do mammals like
themselves i don't know how much do you
have to lick yourself and where you know
so here's the thing
a there's fat on these hairs right
and for one thing we spend a lot of time
is there is there fat on hairs sure
they're oily a little bit uh but there's
some fat there's oil glands at the root
of this like sebaceous glands at the
root of hairs which travels down
okay okay
okay okay so you've got fat exposed to
sunlight which causes this production of
vitamin d which can then be
ingested which i thought was a much more
amazing answer than i i really that's
extraordinary yeah now i'm trying to
remember what the answer was on the on
the nocturnal critters and just like
what about whales
oh yes i don't know
but
like they don't lick themselves and
they're hairless anyway-ish
right but they do
so well they're kind of naked actually
they're kind of naked and they have to
surface so you would imagine
that that that's a solvable
issue
i have so many questions
i know what they are squid naked mole
rats
no they're mostly about squid
make them all right sure right i mean
because well it's it's the it's the
brief
overland now it's the liquid what is it
what i don't know but there's not enough
of that it's the roots it's gotta be the
tubes yeah it's the tubers yeah
okay
um i fear to vax my baby because of this
nonsense any resources to help us we
want to protect her against disease but
no longer trust the system oh you're
talking about all the i get it all the
things yeah
well god damn these people for putting
us in this predicament now that we know
that what they're capable of right it
does raise questions and we don't like
having those questions either and i
guess i would say
i would look very carefully at the
massively increased schedule of
vaccinations yeah automatic vaccinations
and i would say
that probably where this is going to you
as an individual can't do this probably
you should just
go along with it except there are places
where i would probably
opt out but and you can spread it out
and you can slow it down you spread it
out and you can slow it down right like
the the like you know
eight i don't i don't remember what the
schedule is um
um but just
not having them all
at the same time and having having them
as late in development as possible is
bound to reduce and not just accepting
all of them because they're current all
of them are currently recommended but i
really want to know i really want to
know if we are supposed to get some
advice
about what not to eat for example for
what period of time after a vaccination
with an adjuvant in it so this this
would be one thing with regard to your
your children is
what brett has just alluded to is
if the adjuvant which is precisely
supposed to basically irritate your
immune system into being responsive to
the vaccine
um does its job
then your
body may develop a kind of
well potentially autoimmunity that would
be even worse but um anything that you
take into your body in the call it two
weeks who knows um after you get
vaccinated your kid gets vaccinated um
your your body may then develop an
immune response to it which would then
later on be called an allergy and so you
might very well and this would be true
for all of us at any time but more true
for kids um the younger you are the more
the more risk you are
want to consider a pared-down diet
such that there are fewer things in the
system um
after vaccination that the that the
that the body might respond to and
thereafter make a lifelong dietary
problem as a result the problem is you
and i are guessing at this and it's a
very educated guess but
this is noah
and 100 now it may even be known and
frankly anyone who's making any of these
needs is under a clear moral and medical
obligation to have done this work right
and what's what they didn't even in the
case of covet vaccines right the period
of time while you are developing
immunity to the vaccine is a special
period and you don't get nearly enough
information you get this [ __ ]
information that's like oh you're not
fully protected yet and the point is
that ain't the half of it yeah right
yeah so
yeah
ah
boy yeah oh boys right okay we are we're
running out of time
uh is cowardice evolution driven
uh you rebellion rebellion kills you of
course it is yes well but but both see
the problem is that courage and
cowardice are both evolution driven
and so this is one of these things where
it's not like
okay you know
is rape an evolutionary strategy yes are
laws against rape an evolutionary
strategy yes right evolution is not
pointing to one thing it's there's
tensions around things and in the case
of cowardice there are definitely
moments
at which uh you know
oh god
he's affected my perception there's
definitely moments when you don't want
to leroy jenkins your way into a
situation that would be a terrible move
doctor rollergator
um
i have no idea what we're talking about
there's apparently a thing where
here's the thing
there are famous i feel like i missed
one word i have no i have no idea what
even the subject is i don't know what a
leroy jenkins is leroy jenkins is a
person who had a character in a
group video game
who charges you to know this no
except that you know dr rollergate and
he is liable to have said this around
you and and
but in any case
there are moments
when i could use some more soup right
about now yeah well sure i mean this is
good um there are moments when your
fears ought to dominate and there are
moments in which your courage ought to
dominate and your mind is a complex
device for figuring out where you are
and what the better part of valor is
and
so
like that and yes you have chronic
cowards and you have people who are way
too bold and
get themselves hurt yep yep
okay um let's try to get like quickly
just
a few a few more questions okay i really
actually want to answer all of them
today and we're not going to be able to
how do you cook
type of pots pans utensils would love a
cookbook you're heroes i love this
question i want to spend a long time on
this question but we don't we don't have
time right now i will say i love wooden
utensils and we have um cast iron pans
and we have um some uh
what is it called carbonized steel we
have a carbonized steel
thing and then we have um
just stainless and then we have some
coconuts like you know le creuset the
fancy enameled enamel cast iron
um
and
basically nothing nothing with that
non-stick coating on it um you know the
cookie sheets are
you know aluminum's not perfect but
aluminum or steel
um and
you just you know you use you use enough
fat or parchment paper so that things
don't stick or you know you're gonna
have to scrub the hell of it to clean it
off
but if you're gonna get
lodge makes a special
sponge
for
getting stuff that's stuck on to cast
iron pans off without chainmail without
it is chainmail without destroying the
uh the seasoning and you need one of
those because otherwise
you'll end up either wrecking the
seasoning or not being able to get stuff
off yeah yeah
i will say that um you know our pans are
heavy because they're all made of
iron right and so i can see
um you know especially what is that it's
like a
it's a 12 i can't remember if we have a
10 12 or like a 12 and a 14 but like the
the larger of the just the cast iron
skillets we've got it's actually
yeah zack thinks it's 14. it's heavy
and the giant cocoa that we've got like
these things are heavy and some people
just can't wrestle that kind of
kind of weight around um it takes a
village
oh my god
our animals evolved
don't start with me weinstein
well i was either gonna quote hillary
clinton or donald rumsfeld and so you
got the clinton reference
i can't believe that i think i prefer
that you quote donald trump of course
are you kidding
yes
100 yeah
i mean if if we're talking about the not
knowing and the known unknowns and the
known knowns the unknown unknowns and
the unknowns that one yeah yeah yeah i
mean he's got a good few good ones he
was the step now right yes
he was the yogi bear of the military
industrial complex
yeah he was uh you know what you know
one of the advantages he had over uh
hillary clinton
more wizzywig
yeah
um i mean
yeah the the wig part was a little
troubling but it was oh for sure
yeah now though he he he had a lot more
wizzy than to him yeah but uh the
portrayal in vice the movie vice
uh gives you a window into the man
that's another that's another movie to
watch yeah okay our animals evolved to
make friends across species
the ones we've domesticated
um for four friends you know cats and
dogs
yeah we have
as brett mentioned last week he thinks
cats could use a few more thousand years
but
the cats have still not forgiven me for
saying that no he's not he's been in
full punk mode this week
you know he'll come around just give him
a few thousand years yeah
um
i will say
uh
birds and mammals are flexible critters
yeah and that means there are going to
be some oddballs that do some things
that selection didn't necessarily
envision or see and so you're going to
have some instances i don't think in
general this has been built into them um
but you know i i was fascinated as a kid
by these stories of gorillas that had
pet cats yeah right i mean it just makes
so much sense right
i met one of those gorillas once did
yeah yeah i mean i was i was yeah it's a
long story but yeah i was going to be
doing a
internship with coco
so but
it didn't it didn't end up being what it
seemed so
anyway but yeah gorillas with cats yeah
amazing um okay quickly thoughts on
renaming cis and trans to organic versus
processed
half joking
um yeah it's not the worst idea i've
ever heard actually so that's telling
you something um
myocarditis from the vaccine and
myocarditis from covid compound risk or
not
yeah
um
[Music]
first of all
it's not so clear that there is
myocarditis from covid
really yeah because the categories have
been so shuffled in order to do the
skullduggery sure but so so here chris
martin
different yes i i i know it to be a
different kind of an apparently worse
kind of myocarditis from the vaccines
but i thought it was also i think we
don't have good data but there's a
question about where myocarditis was in
2020
you mean in 2019 no 2020 pre-pre-vaccine
oh oh okay so if you're going to play
but you'd also want to know so you want
to i mean we get the 2019 2020 2021 that
would those three comparisons would do
it yeah
pre-covered coveted pre-vaccine and
everything yep
um
finally thoughts on western price and
his book nutrition and physical
degeneration
yeah i've got it i've got it downstairs
it's powerful um i think you know he
basically he was a predecessor to like
mew and the other sort of evolutionary
orthodontists and dentists who are who
are working today and it was
in part in large part his work
um that revealed actually this isn't
just what it is to be human this is what
it is to be a modern this is our word
not his his but a hyper novel human
all this all this crazy
dental and facial
mess that so many so many modern humans
have now yes the whole field of
orthodontia pulled the leroy jenkins and
rushed in with their
their tension generating devices and
never mind
i think i think we're done
thank you i want to ask you questions
about what exactly you mean by we're
done at the end of this and we will
maybe see you next week
all right um once again uh the question
asking period is open on my patreon
right now for our monthly q a which will
be not
this sunday
this sunday but um but next sunday
um and uh you can ask logistical
questions of our fabulous moderator
darkhorse moderator gmail.com
um lots of other stuff but
be good to the ones you love eat good
food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you